Key Management As we've talked about in the cryptography sections,
Key Management is incredibly important.
There's one very good reason for that, and it's actually known as Kirchhoff's principle.
Kirchhoff's principle states that a crypto system should be secure,
even if everything about the system is known except the key.
So an attacker can know the ciphertext.
They can know the algorithm that's being used.
They can know the initialization vector.
They can know all of this, but as long as the key is kept secret,
then you'll have a secure system.
And so key management, how we generate, how we distribute,
how we change or rotate keys, how we distribute those keys,
how we destroy those keys, and then finally, if we need to recover those keys,
it's incredibly important that we do all this very well.
So let's walk through each of these steps.
And let's start with key generation, or creation of keys.
Now when we talk about creating a key, what we're actually doing is we have the key space
that we've talked about, all the possible combinations of a key.
And key generation is about randomly selecting one key out of that entire key space.
And we want to randomly select a key.
It would be a very bad idea if our key generation process simply picked keys one after another
in a linear fashion.
Because what do we always want to avoid in cryptography?
Patterns.
And so we need to be able to, as randomly as possible, select a key from the entire key space.
So that's really what key generation is about.
And this has to be an automated process because human beings we are terrible at true randomness.
And so we need to get our computer systems to try and randomly select a key,
except there's one slight wrinkle there.
And that is our computer systems that we used today are also not capable of actually generating truly random numbers.
But what we can use are what are known as pseudo random number generators.
These are generators that, while not truly random,
they're pretty much close enough.
You know, they won't start to reproduce patterns until maybe billions of years down the road.
So good enough to sort of randomly select a key from the entire space, key space.
So that's key generation.
Next is key distribution.
Especially with symmetric keys.
Once a symmetric key has been generated, you've now got the very big problem of how do you get that key
to the other part of that you're communicating with.
We've already talked about one method out of band.
But that's not very efficient. It's often very difficult to do that.
Another method that you could use is key wrapping.
Key wrapping sounds confusing, but let me explain it in a very simple way.
Let's say that you're planning on communicating with someone all week long
and every hour you want to change keys.
So you're going to need a whole bunch of keys, symmetric keys, to communicate with this person all week long.
So to make this process more efficient, what you decide to do is generate a whole bunch of symmetric keys.
Maybe you generate a hundred of them.
And then what you do is you take those hundred symmetric keys, you put them in a bundle,
and you encrypt all of them with one symmetric key.
So you take a whole bunch of symmetric keys, encrypt them with one symmetric key.
And now you only have to do one key distribution.
You only have to communicate that securely, that one key so that you can then securely send the ciphertext of all the other keys.
That's key wrapping, encrypting a bunch of keys with another symmetric key.
And of course the other major method that you can use that we've talked about is hybrid key distribution,
where you use a combination of asymmetric and symmetric.
You use the asymmetric cryptography to send the symmetric key.
Now let's talk about where you actually store the encryption keys.
There's two major physical devices that we're going to talk about here.
First, TPMs, trusted platform modules.
A TPM is actually a little microchip that is built into the motherboard of a system,
to the hardware of a computer system, like a laptop, a server, a cell phone.
A TPM module is actually a tiny little crypto processor that's used to generate and more importantly, store encryption keys.
And a great way to think about this is you've probably heard of this concept of whole drive encryption,
where you encrypt an entire hard drive, so that if a laptop is stolen for instance,
the attacker won't be able to decrypt the data.
But if you're using whole drive encryption, where are the encryption keys stored?
They obviously can't be on the hard drive because if the attacker had the hard drive with the keys on it,
they'd just be able to unlock it.
And this is where TPM modules come in.
If you ever use a device that supports whole drive encryption,
it has to have one of these TPM modules in it because it's on the TPM trusted platform module
that the encryption keys are actually stored.
And these modules are specifically built to be very difficult to break into,
so that even if someone does steal your laptop,
it's very difficult for them to actually extract the keys from a TPM module.
The next type of device we'll talk about is what's known as an HSM, a hardware security module.
And HSM is also designed to securely store keys,
but not just for an endpoint, like a TPM.
Instead, an HSM module stores the encryption keys for the entire organization.
So an HSM module basically just looks like a server, a very hardened server.
It's plugged to the network and you can communicate with an HSM over the network to request the certain keys or to store certain keys.
So just remember, TPM for storing the key keys on an endpoint,
HSM for storing keys for the entire organization.
Next, let's talk about key rotation.
So key rotation is the concept that's a good idea to change your encryption keys on a periodic basis.
The idea here is that if someone were to compromise or figure out your keys,
if you're changing the keys on a periodic basis,
then they'll only get a small amount of your data and not all of it.
So that's the idea of key rotation.
If you ever get a question asking you how often you should rotate your keys,
what do you think the answer would be?
The perfect answer is as often as necessary,
because it's going to entirely depend on the value of the system,
how critical, how valuable the data is that's being encrypted.
And so for very valuable systems, I'll give you an example.
Some VPN solutions that are passing very important data back and forth across the VPN,
they can be rotating encryption keys every few seconds.
Other keys you might rotate only every year.
So it all depends on the value of the system.
Next, let's talk about key recovery.
So if you've accidentally lost or destroyed your keys, how do you get them back?
There's three major methods that you need to know about.
The first is split knowledge.
And the idea behind split knowledge could be as simple as write the key on a piece of paper,
cut the piece of paper in half, give the two pieces of paper to two different people,
and you've split the knowledge of the key.
There's much more advanced ways of doing this so that if part of the paper is lost,
you can recover it and stuff, but split knowledge is simply the idea that you split the knowledge of the key
up amongst two or more different people.
Next is what's known as dual control.
When I think of dual control, I always think about how do they launch the nuclear missiles out of a submarine.
You always have to have the captain in the first mate.
They each put their keys in some sort of console, turn them both at the same time,
and then whew, the missiles launch.
That's the idea behind dual control.
Two or more people have to work together to recover the keys.
Perfect example of this would be a safe.
Where the safe has both the key and a pinpad.
One person would have the key, the other person would have the pinpad,
code, they'd have to work together, dual control too, unlock the safe.
The final method is key escrow.
This is the idea that you store your encryption keys with a trusted third party,
an organization that's specifically in the business of securely storing encryption keys.
Now one final piece, and that is key destruction or key disposition.
How do you go about destroying your encryption keys?
There are instances where you absolutely have to have destroyed every single copy of the key,
and an example of that is what's known as crypto shredding.
So crypto shredding is the idea that you want to be able to securely destroy your data,
but you're not able to use the best destruction method, which is physical destruction of the media.
So think of storing data in the cloud.
If you have data stored in the cloud, and you say to your cloud provider,
hey, I want you to destroy all of my data.
Are they going to destroy the media, the hard drives the data is stored on?
Of course not, because lots of other customers' data is on those same hard drives.
So this is where you could potentially use crypto shredding.
What you would do is you would make sure that your data was all encrypted in the cloud,
and then you would destroy, and listen carefully here, you would destroy every single copy of the key.
And if you've destroyed every single copy of the key, then the data has been crypto shredding.
Crypto shredding.
No one can recover the data because the keys are gone.
And then you could say to your cloud provider, okay, I've crypto shredding my data,
go ahead and delete the data.
The important part here is you're actually crypto shredding the data.
It's a defensible destruction method that you could potentially use in the cloud.
You